THERE'S GROWING ANGER INSIDE OF RUSSIA,
IN THE AFTERMATH OF A DEADLY
NEW YEAR'S DAY STRIKE ON
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS IN UKRAINE'S
OCCUPIED DONETSK REGION.
SOME SAY RUSSIAN COMMANDERS
IGNORED THE DANGERS, THEIR OWN
SOLDIERS, ONE RUSSIAN LAWMAKER
IS EVEN CALLING FOR PUNISHMENT.
ALSO DISPUTES OVER THE NUMBER
OF RUSSIAN TROOPS KILLED IN
THAT ATTACK.
WARNING THAT RUSSIA IS PLANNING
A PROLONGED ATTACK, UKRAINE IS
GETTING BETTER AT TAKING OUT
DRONES AND SAVORING SMALL
VICTORIES.
>> INTERPRETER: OUR TASK IS TO
--
HUGE SHOT DOWN DRONE, SHOT DOWN
MISSILE, EACH DAY WITH
ELECTRICITY FOR SCHEDULES OF
POWER OUTAGES.
>> CNN'S SCOTT MCLAIN JOINS US
NOW FROM KYIV.
THIS ATTACK ON MAKIIVKA, IS
INTERESTING TO SEE THE TOLL
NUMBERS FROM UKRAINIANS.
INTERESTINGLY, THE CRITICISM
THAT IS COMING WITHIN RUSSIA,
ON COMMANDOES OPERATING ON THE
GROUND, TAKE US THROUGH THE
LATEST.
>> YOU ARE NOT HEARING ANY
CRITICISM FROM WITHIN RUSSIA OF
THE UKRAINIANS.
THIS IS WAR.
WHAT YOU ARE HEARING THOUGH IS
CERTAINLY SOME LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION WITH THE MILITARY
AND LEADERS WHO ALLOWED THIS TO
HAPPEN, SO MANY RUSSIAN TROOPS
AND EQUIPMENT AND WEAPONRY TO
BE ESSENTIALLY IN THE SAME
PLACE AT THE SAME TIME
ESPECIALLY ON NEW YEAR'S EVE
WHEN RUSSIA WAS LAUNCHING
STRIKES OF ITS OWN.
ESSENTIALLY MAKING THE TROOPS
AND EQUIPMENT SITTING DUCKS
MAKING THEM PRETTY EASY TARGETS
AS WELL.
TEN MONTHS INTO THE WAR, THEY
ARE SAYING THE LESSONS OUGHT TO
HAVE BEEN LEARNED BY NOW.
PLENTY OF OPEN BUILDINGS AND
PLACES FOR RUSHING SO THAT THEY
ARE NOT DISPERSED, PRO RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS FROM THE DENOTES
PEOPLES REPUBLIC SUGGESTING
THAT THE RUSSIAN MILITARY HAS
UNDERSTOOD THE CAPABILITY OF
THE UKRAINIAN HIMARS SYSTEM.
--
IF YOU BELIEVE THE UKRAINIANS
THE DEATH TOLL WAS 300 WITH 400
INJURED.
THE NUMBERS AT THIS STAGE ARE
63.
THE PRO-RUSSIAN OFFICIAL IN
THAT DPR E. JEAN SAYS HE
EXPECTS THAT THE FINAL NUMBER
IS IN THE HUNDREDS, OR AT LEAST
MORE THAN 100 AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE LATEST PICTURE FROM THE
SCENE, IT IS A PILE OF RUBBLE,
DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE HOW ANYONE
COULD'VE SURVIVED THIS.
ONCE A VOCATIONAL SCHOOL IN
MAKIIVKA, WE ALSO HAVE
SATELLITE PICTURES WHICH ARE
LITTLE BIT BLURRY WHICH WAS
ONCE THAT SQUARE, THAT
VOCATIONAL SCHOOL, IT SEEMS
LIKE HEAVY EQUIPMENT, TRYING TO
PICK THROUGH THE RUBBLE AND
COUNT THE DEAD BUT THERE IS NO
CONFIRMATION FROM THE RUSSIAN
SIDE ON HOW HIGH OR IF THAT
DOES FALL WILL INCREASE.
>> SCOTT MCLAIN, THANK YOU SO